my next presenter is a man who needs an
introduction but this this is not
because he's not a star of stage screen
and television he's actually one of the
biggest stars in each of those fields
it's just that he's a writer he's
received two Ice Kannamma nations for Oh
God and for twits II and he won the Tony
Award for a funny thing happened on the
way to the forum
he developed co-produced and wrote quite
a lot the one of my favourite TV series
mash he's without question one of our
best I always enjoy seeing this man's
name at the beginning of a script and on
the end of an introduction ladies and
gentlemen Larry Gelbart
the successful screenwriter one who is
the author of more than a clever set of
license plates is a poet pragmatist
ready at the drop of a hold button to
change the script so that the part of
Mother Teresa can be played by Goldie or
dusty or Whoopi and if the writer is
ready and willing but considered unable
perhaps a problem of water on the brain
that the director has no trouble walking
across the writer
the writer is either either rewritten or
partnered with one or more collaborators
often unknown to each other until their
hands meet over the same award here are
this year's triumphant survivors of a
system that would have made the marquis
de sade I uncle
the nominees for the best screenplay
based on material from another medium
are the color purple screenplay by
Mentos emmaus kiss of the Spider Woman
written by Leonard Schrader
out of Africa screenplay by kurt lidtke
preaches honor
screenplay by Richard Condon and Janet
Roach the trip to bountiful screenplay
by horton Foote and the winner the
winner is cartload key for Out of Africa
I was very much honored by the company
in which I was nominated Frank price
made possible first the script and then
the movie Judith Thurman Karen Blixen
biographer was a rich source of
intelligence and insight and invective
and became a friend I'm grateful to
David ray field for his help both
writing and editing
mrs. Gummer thank you very much
the nominees for Best Screenplay written
directly for the screen are Back to the
Future written by Robert Zemeckis and
Bob Gale
brasil screenplay by terry gilliam Tom
Stoppard and Charles Nepean
the official story written by Louise
blends oh and I eat aborting it the
Purple Rose of Cairo written by Woody
Allen
witness screenplay by Earl W Wallace in
William Kelly story by William Kelly
Pamela Wallace and Errol W water the
winners are Earl W Wallace William Kelly
in town
well I want to thank the members of the
Academy and I have to say hi to
Christopher I have an uneasy feeling my
career just peaked but I would like I
would like to thank all of the marvelous
talent that converged on our screenplay
that's from the bottom of my heart
further there was one person who when
the screenplay was finished put wheels
on it that was Nancy Hudson my manager
personally and publicly thank you Nancy
and Christopher is past your bedtime
I would like to thank all my friends on
shore of course and all my friends off
shore but I'll refrain from doing that
yet I would like to thank Paramount and
ed Feldman for taking our script and
making the vision we had as for the
vision of the Academy all I can do is
repeat the words a pumphrey Bogart
here's looking at you kid